- People really believe in
that Illuminati shit, huh?
- [Jason] Oh yeah.
- Do you believe in it?
- [Jason] Um.
- Tell the truth, don't fucking,
don't go based on the
way I said it up, Jason.
Speak your truth, you know I won't judge.
(whooshing)
(TV test tone)
- [Announcer] We interrupt our program
to bring you this important message.
(TV test tone)
- Instagram, I just went
H.A.M. on my dad's business.
Always trying to innovate, help my pops,
came up with a ridiculous concept.
The least friction ever,
the most convenient way ever to buy wine,
the link is in my profile right now.
Go sign up ASAP.
You're part of the first
little group in the beta test,
winetext.com.
You sign up right now,
takes you a minute or two.
And then going forward,
every day you get an offer on
ridiculously discounted wine.
This 45 dollar pinot is
gonna be 18 bucks in an hour.
That's right 18.
The easiest way to buy anything ever.
You get a ridiculous steal,
you know multiple times a week.
And all you have to do
when you get the text
is reply with a number.
Four, and four bottles are on there way.
I just went on it,
I flexed it on a wine business,
I helped out my pops.
Winetext.com, get on it now.
Sign up now.
Share this now.
Hit in your story now.
Wine lovers, rejoice.
(uptempo music)
You got your perspective.
(airplane engine roaring)
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy.
(loud drum beat)
You could literally
create the Thanksgiving game,
cops versus firefighters.
(rewind tape)
Working backwards, you have a law firm.
(bell ringing)
(soft soul music)
- [Man] Yes.
- And we want to get people's businesses.
And so,
we, first responders
are incredibly to that?
- [Man] If they know and
like you and trust you,
from the stunts that you've
been doing, content, and
- Yup.
I totally agree.
So just as somebody, thank God,
hasn't been in this scenario yet
and just have been dug
in, some accident happens
and the relatives that are left over
that aren't at the
hospital may look at a cop
or first responder and say,
"Can you give me a lawyer right now?"
- [Man] Who can help us?
Right?
- Yeah.
It's cool, I just have never
- [Man] Yeah, hardest to, first to
- Yeah I totally understand.
What I'm really good at
is not knowing anything
and asking questions.
Right?
Curiosity.
And lack of education has been
an incredible foundation for me,
but you think about all that stuff
on remittent television
where the lawyers are there.
Right?
And I'm like,
you know and then when
I got older I'm like,
when I started like, just through like
being in a business
cocktail you hear like some
of those companies are sizable businesses.
And I'm like makes sense, right?
And so when I started
going to this version.
No different than like,
hey guys make something
that's valuable to people
instead of
Right?
I was like, man.
I even think in my earliest videos,
when I was talking about personal brand.
I was like, be the lawyer
that tells people all the real shit.
Like, like I just feel like that's great.
That makes so much sense to me.
So now, I understand that now.
So now what you're asking
me is targeting capability,
that if you're in a town
that all the cops are Irish American.
Like how do I win that?
- [Man] Like building
basically with in that.
- Cohorts.
- [Man] How do I best go about,
um, becoming the alpha in each one
of these communities?
- In the psycho and
demographic communities.
By providing each one of
them what they're looking
for either in the macro or the micro
of what you do for a living.
So, you know, the reason that SMB works
for me so much is like I'm trying
to tell them to put out content
about how to hot fire a relative,
has nothing to do with their product.
But I know that it's a
huge value to actual SMB's.
I think the answer is.
The way I think about
that is, you take the.
How many different communities
do you think there are?
Intuitively.
- [Man] I know there's
a ton, I mean, Right?
So you have to narrow down three, or one,
or four that you can go for these people.
- And I think you, what
you do is you white board
the 10 that you think
are the most meaningful,
then rank them.
And then really go deep
in the first three,
of like really spending time.
Weather reading, weather
actually spending time.
But it's the strategy and insights
to make what they like,
what makes them tick.
And then providing that
weather through content form
or event form.
It's really one big game
of reverse engineering.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like this is something
I've wanted to do for years,
but until I felt like everybody.
For the far majority of people
would leave here ROY
positive in their investment.
Like the thought of like building up
everything I've built up.
Or like you two brothers don't do it
and then leave.
And then say Gary Vee is a
farce I've spent 12,000 bucks
and it didn't get me anything.
That's just stupid business for me.
I needed to get to a
place where I thought,
this was so overwhelmingly
ROY positive, you know.
And that's how I think about everything.
Literally everything.
Sneakers, wine, intermedia.
Until you're, you know,
Until you get to a place.
And so, that's just what
I want you to kinda do.
It's like what does, what does, why
- [Man] The only thing that I can do,
That I can think of is
basically copying your motto
we touched on for the lawyer aspect
and I can have all my friends come in
and be the top lawyer guy
in that community, right?
But as I get more awareness
in the first responder group,
I would love to have a
show of the firefighter
comes through the car wreck,
the ER nurse is the first
person in the hospital having
like a little drama.
With people throughout the community
that would have different.
- I don't know if you wanna
go, you, I mean listen.
You're just a creative guy,
I can already sense that.
So you've just may want to do that.
I actually think its a little
less, ER, and Law and Order.
I think you make it a little
bit more, so I'm a big fan.
And I'm sure you guys
have heard of this about
like hosting the party.
I think one of the things you can do is
just create a podcast network.
So like I think you should go
find two charismatic nurses
and start a Houston nursing show.
You're the executive
producer, they're the talent.
And that becomes a little
viral hit in that community.
You see where I'm going?
Uh, I'll give you a real left field one
if you wanna be super creative.
You could also, this is crazy,
but I would love for you to do this.
I think this is super cool.
You could actually be the live streamer
of the cops and firefighters
soft ball league.
What if you acted like ESPN.
Had 6 people with live streaming,
and actually aired the
softball league games.
Yeah I mean if you're lucky enough
and you live in one of those towns where
the cops do play against the firefighters.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Or you could literally
create the Thanksgiving game.
Cops versus firefighters.
Get a field, get a high
school to support it.
Film it and air it live on Facebook,
and own the, you know,
the first responders cup.
You could probably get
a sponsor to come over
and subsidize all you're fuckin' fees.
(laughing)
you could literally throw the
fuckin' Thanksgiving game.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Every fuckin' Friday,
you see where I'm going?
- [Man] I think I wanna do, I wanna create
basically the best.
- I think it's a lot easier to throw.
I think the best thing you can
throw is a literal podcast.
The most likely thing you can
pull off is a podcast network.
The next more likely
thing you can pull off
is actually airing the softball games,
or the football games.
The last thing you're
probably likely to pull off
is creating ER.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You're not producing a show.
- [Man] Okay.
- That's hard as fuck.
Scripted?
- [Man] It would be like interview based.
- That's different.
That's different.
- [Man] Tell me your experience.
- That's different, that's different.
That's different.
That's different, but less
reoccurring than the things.
- [Man] It'll be harder to go
deep on the episodes for sure.
- And it'll be one off.
Once you interview Karen, where is?
- [Man] Gotta have more people.
- Where is if you're doing a
show for nurses, in Houston.
And just the culture of that,
and it's a call in show.
You see where I'm going?
You wanna create things
that are like scalable.
Wine Library TV was
amazing, I tasted wine.
Which meant I could live 400 life times,
and never get to every wine.
Right?
Ask Gary Vee.
Think about the shows I've made.
The wine, Wine Library TV.
Scalable in perpetuity.
I can't taste every wine in my life.
Not in 100 life's.
Ask Gary Vee.
Unlimited questions from
the audience, forever.
Daily vlog.
I actually live, just film me.
(laughing)
There's never, I never had to create.
See where I'm going?
- [Man] Yeah.
- See?
- [Man] That's really smart.
- Got it?
That's what you're looking for.
(lighthearted music)
- What up, what up, what up?
What is up Instagram?
Hope everyone's having a good afternoon,
I'm about to go on a
board call in 8 minutes.
So I don't have a whole lot of time.
Maybe 5 or 6.
When's the next Illuminati meeting?
People really believe in
that Illuminati shit huh?
- [Jason] Oh yeah.
- Do you believe in it?
Tell the truth don't fuckin',
don't go based on the
way I set it up, Jason.
Speak your truth you know I won't judge.
(high intensity music)
- [Jason] Yes.
- You do?
- [Jason] I think so, I don't know.
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- [Jason] There's gotta be
a like big group of like,
just like I don't know, like.
- Like Dr. fuckin' Evil's ?
- [Jason] Something.
I don't think there's like
one dude behind the show.
- Of course there's no
- [Jason] There's gotta be someone like.
- This is not a fuckin' joke.
This is really me asking
for the first time.
I actually have no idea
what the people think
the Illuminati, Is the
Illuminati this theory
that like powerful people
have a secret club?
- [Jason] Yeah.
- Jay-Z.
Yeah I get it right?
But that's more of a
diamond than fuckin' like,
like but that's the punch line right?
Got it.
I mean there's definitely people
that get together and jam.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- You believe in the Illuminati?
- Some what.
- You do, you do.
- [Jason] We've seen
so many YouTube videos,
like that probably describe it.
You ever just like.
- Oh you want it to be real, to be in it?
- [Man] I don't know about that.
- I feel like I'm in the
Illuminati, a club of one.
I think the coolest club I'm
in is in my fuckin' head,
with myself.
That's the fuckin' Illuminati for me.
That's the Illuminati
I wish everybody had.
Be in your own fuckin' head with yourself.
That's fuckin' Illuminati.
You wanna really fuckin',
fuck like other high net worth individuals
that are powerful or famous
or cool or good looking.
Like that sounds like club of insecurity.
And needing to fuckin' fit
into something elitist.
The real Illuminati is
in your own fuckin' dome.
Club of one.
Membership of one.
(techno music)
- Hello
- It's so nice to meet you.
- I'm with Gary Vee!
- Such a pleasure.
- Hey how are you?
Good to see ya!
How have you been?
- Good how are you
- Sup?
- Thank you.
- How are you ?
- Hi, how are you?
- Hey, how are you?
- Good to see you.
Good to see you.
- Nice to see you.
- Nice to see you again.
- What's up brother?
- How are you doing?
How are you bro?
Walk with me for a sec.
Thank you gang.
Thank you, thanks for all your help.
Thank you, I'll see you guys
later, or back at the office.
Uh, it was good right?
That concept is good.
- Yeah.
(rhythmic music)
- [Jason] Gary, when's
the last time you've been
in this kitchen?
- Never
(laughing)
(rhythmic music)
- Thank you for being here,
I'm really excited about tonight.
Uh, you know, Vayner has been
a very organic organization
over the last decade and
so as we continue kind
of to our next phase.
We haven't done a whole
lot of events like this.
And so, I'm just very
grateful for the PET team,
what we call our HR team, here.
And uh, just wanna thank all of you
for putting this together, I
was really excited about it.
(clapping and cheering)
I also haven't been in the
kitchen for about a year
and a half so it's good
to see it's still here.
Good call Jason.
(rhythmic music)
- The biggest mistake that people make
when they think about aca
lades is the same reason
that they dwell on the booing.
You know it's funny that
we're talking about athletes,
uh, you know, over the last
decade I've built a lot
of friendships in that world.
And then over the last half decade,
a lot of the world has become this.
Right?
And a lot of people come to me
because I grew up in that world.
And people get down on
somebody leaving a comment
that's negative and I'm like,
"bro, you play on home
court, given up an 11-0 run,
and everybody who's supposed
to be your homies are booing you."
And you don't let that phase you
because you're in that zone.
As a human you need to be in that zone.
When people are saying
you're the greatest,
you need to think you're crap.
When people say you're crap,
you need to think you're the greatest.
And in that contradiction and pulling
from opposite directions,
when the flows going one way.
That's how you get your actual balance,
that's how you get your
two fingers in your ears.
You don't hear shit.
Can I cures on this thing?
Good.
You don't hear shit.
You don't hear if they say
you're going to be the MVP
in the league your rookie year.
And you don't hear if that you're
the biggest bust of all time.
And the second you can get there,
get into that place, it's over and so.
Don't get too high on your
own supply, your clippings.
A lot of these kids have serious heat.
Some of these kids have
the most heat we've seen
in a generation.
And you know, balancing
that is imperative.
So for me, you know,
what I see in other A's,
when I'm going through a bit
in my little world is just,
don't hear it.
One way or the other.
(energetic music)